four months four years the whole of
government has been beavering away
trying to come up with a solution to
keeping the Irish border open and
without checkpoints after we leave the
European Union Tory brickster say the
issue is a phantom one because there's
an easy solution we are showing how you
can use existing technologies and
management techniques to deliver a
managed border of Brussels then are
discussing actively some of the
technical ways of dealing with this that
I think will arrive for a breakthrough
slight problem the government isn't so
sure Sky News has obtained the contents
and slides of a presentation compiled by
the Home Office which looked into this
exact question it outlines the
government's best guess for how a
technological solution to the border
might work suffice to say it isn't
simple the home office suggests using
four different technologies first
companies would upload their goods data
into a computer system using blockchain
systems
second sensors and the Internet of
Things will detect the goods as they
make their way along the route and send
data back to the government so they know
where and what it is machine learning
would tell authorities if a shipment
look risky and needed inspection and
revenue collection on tariffs will be
automatic so nice and straightforward
then but complexity is not the only
issue
for a start as these documents make
clear there is no government anywhere in
the world which manages to do this
without putting infrastructure at the
border it would require no fewer than 28
government agencies to be involved each
working with their own myriad different
IT systems and there's no budget for
this no pilot work for it hasn't even
begun it would require extensive
cooperation not only from the Republic
of Ireland but from the European Union
as well and here is the absolute kicker
these documents say that similar
technological solutions won't be ready
to be brought online in the United
Kingdom until 2030 this former border
force officer thinks the chance of
something like this working is minimal
their record generally in everything in
relation to borders and indeed policing
has been absolutely abysmal over the
is expecting them to deliver a projects
and complex as they envisage in respect
of the movement of goods across borders
really is is almost almost lovable
in fact why do you think it is then
there's so many politicians say there
are easy technological solutions to this
question because loads do cuz
politicians lie but Tory brickster MPs
as ever think the civil service is
working against them as you know this is
put together by civil servants I think
that there are all sorts of things we
can do to ensure that that can work in
the meantime without this perfect
long-term solution but they can't
identify if we're going to wait for the
long-term solution it may take 10 years
I'm not sure it will I think you'd be
quicker the Home Office refused to
comment tonight
not long ago Sajid Javid the Home
Secretary said the goodwill was what was
needed to get these systems up and
running it's going to take much more
than that
Lewis could all Sky News Westminster